The jogan Experience because with AI
they're going to do that they're going
to make new versions of wuang songs they
already did it with Drake I think that
the thing too is you know how they go oh
likeness and and right like the stars
like hey you know I want to this movie
without Tom Tom Cruz will be like uh no
you cannot use my likeness I'm
protecting it that's like what some of
this like uh uh labor union stuff is
about protecting your your image and
likeness yes but there're I I just feel
like there's you know there's just going
to be one of these offers to one of
these people where they go okay go for
it right $20 million go for
it Bruce Willis has a neurological
condition I I forget I forget what it's
called it's called Aphasia I think I
might have it yeah you're right you're
right talk about bring it back to
yourself of course we're just here
talking about I can't look at a post and
not think about me um he's uh I could
Bruce Bruce Willis sold his likeliness
likess so you can likeness sorry you for
um the purpose of AI he did yes H yeah
find out what that is mean but in in his
position I mean he's incapable of making
money anymore he he has a real issue
he's it's actually very Advanced and
they think this is towards we're at the
close to the end oh my God yeah I follow
his daughter to Lula so no Bruce Wills
didn't sell his likeness to a deep fake
company despite initial reports the Deep
fake company does not own the rights to
Bruce Willis likel likeness uh partially
because that's literally not possible
the company said Willis appeared in a
recent advertisement through deep cake
which managed to create a digital twin
of Willis that can appear in new content
despite the actual Wills retiring from
acting as a result of AP fasia a brain
disorder that hinders cognition and
speech abilities I'd like the Precision
of my character will is set of the
process according to the quote deep deep
Cake website it's a great opportunity
for me to go back in time the neural
network was trained on content of di
hard and Fifth Element so my character
is similar to the images of that
timeo so it's young Bruce Willis doing
ads I sent you guys I sent you guys yeah
that is what they're saying I sent you
guys George Carlin's new special yeah
yeah yeah but hold on a second but hold
on second that seems like that is what
we're saying it feels like that this is
and also this is literal phase one of of
the aist celebrity being like you can
use it for this sure when barbar string
gets to be a certain age Trump's
president again she might say you know
whaton so my young face and also what
about the people who it's not a major
movie making it it's just some YouTube
account oh what happens to dead people
you know what happens like James kagne
their estate what if the estate decides
to the Marland Monroe estate yeah
Charles Bronson sailing soap yeah so
this is the George Carlin one that came
out a couple weeks ago yeah how many
views it says the cover 500k many views
it keeps getting pulled down really it
keeps getting pulled down yeah because
uh George Carlin's daughter Kelly I
think keeps doesn't want bring up oh I
disagree with that this is uh it's put
on a a a YouTube account called dudy
yeah dudy says I'm a comedy AI I like
they wrote this as though dudy made it
if you will uh-huh when you look at what
dudy is dud is a account it's Will Sasso
but they have an AI
that wait wait minute that's where it
becomes like how would Will Sasso have
this super secret AI program hold on
Will Sasso Will Sasso has a podcast if
I'm not mistaken where he has AI bring
up the subjects of the podcast and
that's what they talk about
theoretically thinking this will based
on Research be one of the best podcasts
out there well there's a podcast on it
look click on that it says George car
Resurrected that's what this is so this
that's what I'm trying to say is like
when I was looking into like what is
this George Carlin thing it's on this
account that they called dudy and
they're saying like dudy made this oh so
they made it through AI it's most likely
like that Kanye song we played with Tony
where someone wrote in the in the in the
like and how George Carin would write
and then performed it all and then got
George carin's voice to go over top of
that to a version of his voice oh wait a
minute so AI didn't write the jokes no I
heard a I wrote the jokes that's that's
tough that's where it becomes very tough
you think you're saying that he that AI
didn't write the jokes in this case I
don't know but it seems a lot more like
the fake thing that the Drake song and
the Kanye song where it's not 100% dbe
AI what you're hearing is like an AI
doing a deep fake video like and who
would write who would write it the the
in that case it was the rapper who wrote
the rap song in this case it's probably
comedians who know how to write like on
SK this week they played AI versions of
their stand-ups to the to the Soder Jay
Lewis Dave and and uh one other guy I
forgot um and they were like here's your
AI version of your standup and they just
played it for him and they all broke it
down how was it uh they said it was a
lot of fun it's hard to be worse yeah
butterly yeah
it's hopefully it's not amazing you're
only
got L is like can I use that I feel like
we're joking around about the first rain
shower that comes before the torrential
flood that caused
you're right I think it's going to get
bad it's going to be a new world like
the world is going to be built in a very
hazy way all this stuff about AI
everybody like we all talk it's scary
and you see you know I understand why
riters were like riters Guild was like
really concerned about this and they're
they're concerned by version one dude
like this just started imag first
[__] iPhone and you're like this it's
going to get rid of a lot of shitty
riters that's that's the thing can you
stop stealing Copenhagen TV shows and
fuing make something all those people
keep making the same cop show over and
over again get the [__] out do Mr Mrs
smth the thing it will replace it will
replace a lot of low-level basic [__]
and you'll lose a lot of you still need
your Christopher Nolan to write
Christopher Nolan had to be a shitty
writer first 100% you got to be a shitty
writer first to become Christopher Nolan
yeah you got to build unless you're some
wizard that comes out Char Charlie rare
very R the only thing I think that would
be beneficial would be great if I could
do my podcast with AI and then type in
yo can you take all the annoying parts
of me out of there like when I talk over
you or I talk like like I would love how
about just not talk over people hey kind
Rob it's kind of [__] tough you don't
need a
robot